[Music]
how would you describe the Gulf of
Mexico
Paradise
subtropical Paradise Paradise Grand
Island was Paradise it's a Sportsman's
Paradise diverse abundant strong
resilient Bountiful beautiful
magnificent Perfection home
[Music]
I think that we're facing a situation
where there is relatively little oil
where there is not enough to Warrant the
substantial risk where you've got nobody
knows how many millions of barrels
billions of barrels of oil and how many
trillion our Industries have pioneered
the Technologies used in environmentally
responsible executive branch they were
not prepared to take the rest we are not
prepared to take the rest of the
Secretary of interior was very focused
on and one drill for the billions of
barrels of oil that we have right now
warehoused underground including our
resources offshore we will drill here
drill baby drill and drill now
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
workers are still missing and fear dead
are the rig that exploded on Tuesday has
now sunk threatening a major oil spill
off the Louisiana coast
I
are at the beginning of the end
but there are still a lot of
uncertainties
on the morning of April 20th 2010 there
was a disaster aboard the Deepwater
Horizon drilling rig which killed 11
people and leaked massive amounts of oil
into the Gulf of Mexico
the Gulf which is the lifeblood for so
many hard-working Americans had become
severely damaged and polluted
what caused this tragedy
who was ultimately responsible
and how long was it going to take for
this once Bountiful ecosystem to bounce
back from this severe devastation
to find the answers to these difficult
questions we will need to begin this
investigation by taking a closer look
into BP's history
[Music]
I believe that the fundamentals of BP
are strategy our assets and the high
standards of our people are something we
should all be proud of in 1995 BP hired
mergers and Acquisitions Guru John Brown
as its new CEO Brown had one mission
to make BP the largest oil conglomerate
possible
at any cost
two years later he initiated what was
then the largest merger in history
61 billion dollar takeover of Amaco Arco
Burma Castrol and several other
companies making BP the third largest
private oil company in the world
it was these mergers that caused BP to
face the enormous task of upgrading
numerous aging facilities
managing substantial debt along with
integrating thousands of new employees
[Music]
you might then be asking yourself how
this affected BP's safety culture
not well
in fact the EPA cited BP as the largest
polluter in the United States
this was even more evident when studying
their long history of disasters
the list is shocking
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
since you took over as CEO of VP that's
safe reliable operations are number one
priority correct that is correct and
you've been CEO for the past three years
correct correct then explain to us why
between June of 2007 and February of
2010 the occupational health and safety
administration checked 55 oil refineries
operating in the U.S two of those 55 are
owned by PBP and BP's refineries racked
up 760 citations for egregiously willful
safety violations accounting for 97
percent of the worst and most serious
violations that OSHA monitors in the
workplace that doesn't sound like a
culture of safety
in summary
and the United States alone from 1990 to
2010 BP was responsible
for 8 000 spills
217 injuries
and the deaths of 38 of its own
employees
has also been charged with numerous
felonies and has become infamous for
cutting Corners in order to increase
shareholder profits by any means
necessary
after learning if all BP's willful
safety violations
deaths injuries
environmental disasters and felony
charges
it was astonishing to learn of the
billions in U.S government contracts
they were still receiving
why was the United States government
continuing to fund this blatantly
egregious Behavior
to answer this we must look further into
the past when the need for domestic oil
production became much more prevalent
within the United States government
[Music]
good evening the Middle East War
produced developments all over the world
today the oil producing countries of the
Arab world decided to use their oil as a
political weapon they will reduce oil
production by five percent a month until
the Israelis withdraw from occupied
territories if the Arab countries keep
that pledge it would reduce their
production by almost 50 percent in one
year
as a result of U.S support of Israel and
the Yom Kippur War in 1973 OPEC
announced that it would cut production
and place an embargo on the export of
crude to Western countries
this caused a global spike in oil prices
unlike anything the world had ever seen
after the Embargo
consumers were forced to wait in long
lines at the pump
station owners set limits on the amount
customers could buy and frequently ran
out of gas
regardless of the fact that America
imported less than 50 percent of its oil
from Arab Nations
during this time oil prices increased
330 percent
big oil used the Embargo as political
motivation to open new lands for
domestic Drilling
however this increase in domestic
production would not bring any real
relief at the pumps as the oil companies
decided to keep crude prices High to
maximize profits
this had a devastating impact on
economies across the globe
the U.S responded by creating a new
energy policy and began to look into
Alternative Energy Solutions
but sadly by the end of the 1970s the
lessons of the oil embargo were all but
forgotten and Americans had reverted
back to their previous consumption
habits
ultimately the Embargo changed the way
the United States viewed its dependence
on foreign oil
forcing the nation to take a serious
look into Drilling in its own backyard
Reagan is our projected winner Ronald
Wilson Reagan of California a sports
announcer a film actor a governor of
California is our projected winner
Ronald Reagan was elected president in
1981.
he made the initial push to open
domestic drilling allowing free markets
to rain and trusting The Big Industry
would act morally under Reagan the
Federal Trade Commission took on a new
dismissive approach toward corporate
mergers this environment fostered the
biggest takeovers in corporate history
Exxon and mobile
Chevron and Texaco Conoco and Phillips
and BP with Amaco and then Arco
creating the largest corporations in the
history of the world
the mergers allowed big oil to resurface
as a major owner of oil
and allowed them to exercise their
control over prices through the Futures
Market replacing OPEC as the principal
determinant of the price of crude Ronald
Reagan made promises that we're going to
deregulate everything we're going to get
government out of your life entirely and
that Private Industry is going to do a
better job and we're all going to be
happy with Private Industry Private
Industry is going to be able to deliver
the mail better they're going to be able
to give you health care they're going to
be able to take your children they're
going to be able to take your prisons
they're going to take care of everything
for you it was the biggest lie that has
ever been told to the American public
I am suggesting that there are literally
thousands of unnecessary regulations
that invade every facet of business and
indeed very much of our personal lives
that are unnecessary that government can
do without that have added 130 billion
dollars to the cost of production in
this country
and that are contributing their part to
inflation and I would like to see us a
little more free as we once were we have
only at least out and begun to explore
two percent of our outer continental
shelf
for oil probably 70 percent of the
potential oil in the United States is
probably hidden in those lands and no
one is allowed to even go and explore to
find out if it is there
Big Oil also began taking drilling
operations into deeper waters where
their exploits became much more risky
the government downplayed this risk and
the American public had been convinced
they could rely on the oil industry to
do what was best for the environment and
our way of life
Reagan would pass the torch to his
number two
and finally the oil industry had one of
their own in office
two months later
an oil tanker smashed into a reef near
Valdez Alaska today causing the worst
oil spill since the Alaska pipeline
opened 12 years ago
it is interesting to note that BP owned
alieska the company in charge of the
Exxon Valdez cleanup
by studying The Fallout from the Exxon
Valdez spill
the following cleanup process
we can get an accurate idea of what lies
ahead for the gulf ecosystem and its
residents
we felt that by mentioning alyeska
people would look into it and discover
oh yes it was dominated by BP so we
didn't name those names in retrospect I
wish dearly we had because it could have
caused a change in the internal
corporate climate transparency public
attention makes a huge difference in in
the Exxon Valdez case the attention was
diverted almost entirely on a captain
who had had a few drinks another thing
we believed was
there will only be short-term harm
in the ecosystem
and you know we actually questioned the
scientists on that and it turned out
that that was based on a 1970s science
that had been done for the Clean Air Act
and Clean Water Act
and the scientists didn't have any
reason not to believe it
um it's sort of like the World is Flat
until you suddenly discover the world is
round and then everything changes right
so everything changed with the Exxon
Valdez oil spill the oil that washed
ashore was happened to be in the
nurseries for the pink salmon and the
Herring and the fishermen and the native
people said how can this be you know how
are these little eggs and here's all
this oil what's going to happen so we're
going to wait we're gonna wait we picked
four years because that was when the
Herring should have matured and become
adults was in four years and it's when
the pink salmon the ones that survived
their offspring should have come back as
adults we one of our questions was
what's going to happen to those little
baby fish are they going to be able to
reproduce normally so we picked four
years and it turns out in four years
that's when the ecosystem collapsed in
Prince William sound and all the
scientists were saying how can this be
how can this be so the world was all of
a sudden round and this it took the
scientists another eight years to do all
the laboratory studies and the field
studies to sort of validate the New
World Order you know
um that oil is more toxic than the
scientists thought in the 1970s
basically Hearing in that area crashed
and never came back
after the spill
we lost about estimated 250 000 Birds
seabirds and thousands of including and
we also lost eagles quite a few bald
eagles because they feed on dead carrion
and so anything oiled was Munch time for
them
and we lost a pot of orcas
and we lost a good many sea otters as
well
one group had brain dysfunction and they
had short-term memory loss and they
couldn't concentrate and they they felt
like they were in a fog all the time you
know and uh
then there was another group that had
asthma and and then another group with
hardly irregularities and then just
general malaise chronic fatigue and uh
just couldn't function very well at all
a lot of muscle aches joint aches and
things like that you know Exxon spilled
nearly 11 million gallons of crude into
Prince William's sound
over 500 000 birds and wildlife were
killed and more than six thousand people
would be diagnosed with chronic
illnesses believed to be caused by the
cleanup process
it was becoming clear that the effects
of This Disaster were going to be
serious and long-term
what is in store for the Gulf Coast
residents working on the cleanup
are they going to experience the same
health issues in the next few decades
that the Valdez workers are dealing with
now
[Music]
this era of deregulation led to the
expansion of power for Big Oil in the
United States
the interaction between corporate and
governmental agendas had become blurred
and enabled corporations to influence
elections and U.S policy making like
never before
[Music]
unfortunately with the expansion of
lobbyism in the late 90s this type of
corporate power and influence would
continue to grow exponentially
throughout administrations to come
basically this is an industry that has
been
um dominant in U.S politics for a very
long time but that dominance actually is
only recently been as strong as it is
now in modern history and that really
began around the year 2000 and it really
began with uh the coming into office of
the Bush Administration in the level of
extremes that we're witnessing right now
and and those extremes are the Bush
Administration essentially opening up
new avenues of operation for BPF for the
oil industry
dramatically reducing regulation
dramatically reducing oversight
dramatically reducing enforcement the
oil industry spent more money on the
George W Bush Administration in 2000
than any election in history
for their generosity they received
a president
vice president
Secretary of interior
[Music]
Secretary of Commerce
and Secretary of State
who were all former Oil Company
officials
this Administration did more than any
other to further the interests of Big
Oil through deregulation
lack of enforcement
new access to public lands and oceans
subsidies tax breaks and War
in fact the revolving door between
government and the oil industry is all
too familiar
what we do know is that basically within
the first few days of taking office the
Bush Administration you know gave Cheney
the right to make this task force he was
allowed to call all his best buddies
from his days in the oil industry over
and not just oil but coal and gas and
all these other fossil fuels but he
called the Mover and they had all these
series of meetings here over months to
come up with a a policy plan that would
go on to guide the next year eight years
of this Administration uh you know this
was a this task force document they put
out was basically a wish list for the
oil gas and coal Industries it was you
know asking for ways to weaken
regulations it was asking for numerous
incentives to among other things drill
offshore you name it if it was
supervised if it was overseen if it was
regulated by the federal government
training with His Marvelous bureaucratic
Talent moved in and essentially replaced
the people who were in the positions
that were Central to this regulation
this oversight with people who were
either lobbyist for the industry being
regulated or Executives from that
industry
the bush Cheney Administration enacted
one of the most pro-oil anti-environment
pieces of legislation in history
the energy Policy Act of 2005.
in particular section 390 of the ACT
dramatically extended the circumstances
under which new drilling permits could
be approved without further
environmental review
the minerals Management Service or MMS
which is responsible for the inspection
and oversight of energy companies
approved the project using this type of
categorical exclusion
in fact BP was lobbying to expand the
use of such exemptions less than two
weeks before the Deepwater Horizon
disaster
he destroyed the regulatory mechanisms
in America give us some examples Cheney
left I'm told somewhere around 1600 plus
people in the administration whom he had
converted from being political or he had
recruited his Civil Service he converted
them to civil service if they were
political and left them in these
positions that are very key to
regulation and oversight and those
people will take a year year and a half
maybe even two years for the Obama
Administration to root out and get rid
of
it was astonishing that a federal
regulatory agency was corrupted so
intrinsically by the industry they were
supposed to be regulating
how could this have happened
in 1982 Congress passed the federal oil
and gas royalty management act which
mandates the protection of the
environment and conservation of federal
lands in the course of developing oil
and gas facilities
Reagan chose James Watt to be his
Secretary of the Interior
watt was a controversial figure well
known for his anti-environmental
policies
it was the Federal oil and gas royalty
management act that set it up but it was
specifically to not only exploit the the
offshore resources but to protect the
environment and they certainly have done
a good job on the one hand with
exploiting the resources but they have
done a very poor job with protecting the
environment and you have to remember
that all of these resources are in the
common trust or the public Trust
in spite of fact that you read it
repeatedly over and over the facts are
not one lease or well was drilled in a
park or Wilderness Area during my
predecessor's time or my time or an
Assessor's time because it's just not
desirable or legal did anybody go in
sideways you know they were doing that
weren't they start from the outside and
go in underneath boy you were stinky in
in New Mexico we did one well and we
slant drilled they were outside the
boundaries there yeah they came Drilling
in snaking that old noodle right down in
there yeah and hopefully
found oil so we don't have to be
dependent upon those Persian Gulf States
I don't want to have America in a
hostage situation to the Arabs
surrounding the Persian Gulf Reagan
invented James Watt okay he invented
James Watts because he knew what James
Watts was he was nothing more than an
ideologue buffoon Not only was he not
qualified to do the job his ideology
didn't allow him to do the job he came
from an industry that was that hated
government mineral the mining industry
where he comes from around Wyoming they
hated government because government was
making them actually pay taxes for
taking our natural resources government
was making him when they drilled do it
without destroying our waterways in our
air
watt cut funds for environmental
programs and ensured there would be less
regulation on the federal level
he had no concern for conservation and
proposed that by the turn of the century
all 80 million Acres of U.S Wilderness
become available for drilling and Mining
matter of fact there's something that
you go back and look it's called the
Sagebrush Rebellion the Sagebrush
Rebellion was exactly those mining
people and those that that Western
industry was the Coors family it was
Richard mellencave it was
um the the Koch brothers all of those
guys said we are going to change
government Ronald Reagan was the guy
they put up to do that Ronald Reagan was
a man who'd had no history of
accomplishing anything really they they
put him in office as governor of
California
uh they this is a guy who sold borax
soap on G for General Electric
television I mean what was it I forget
the name of the show we had some western
cowboy show and he sold borax soap so
they take this guy he has a great face
he has a great he talks well and we're
going to put him in government
and so they put him in government but
he's their boy you understand Ronald
Reagan is Corporate America's boy
and so as corporate America's boy they
asked him to deliver something take
government off her back how do they do
that they create new agencies one of
them was mineral management
mineral management was created by Reagan
for ideologue
dimwits like uh like James Watt
so James Watt then does
exactly what we'd expect he hires people
just like him from the top to bottom
they are dimwits they're intellectual
lightweights and more importantly they
are people who are looking for jobs
because they can't get jobs anywhere
else I mean they're minimally qualified
and all every time every time they're
supposed to be regulating
what really they're doing is they're
saying you know at the dinner table with
this Corporation they're supposed to be
regular are you going to give me a job
and so the quid pro quo the trade-off is
if you're going to give me a job I'm
going to let you do what the hell you
want to do
James Watt created the minerals
Management Service to be responsible for
the leasing of public lands exploration
and collection of oil and gas revenue
for the government
as well as to ensure that companies were
operating lawfully and protecting the
safety of their workers and the
environment
[Music]
the gulf would be the main site for deep
water exploration becoming what
environmentalists termed a national
sacrifice area
today 99 of the nation's offshore oil
production occurs in the Gulf
the MMS became a partner to the oil
industry
because they were so interconnected
their regulatory Authority disintegrated
MMS officials ignored environmental
reviews
were lenient in pursuing companies over
equipment failures and abandoned
proposals that would have improved
safety
the resulting imbalance of authority led
to a culture conducive to corruption
there's a concept in in government
called regulatory capture
and that is that the regulating agency
works so closely with the industry they
deal with each other every day they
start to know each other
capture occurs when they deal with when
they become so comfortable that it is
the industry that dictates to the
regulatory agency what happens rather
than the other way around and a lot of
people use the phrase that the the
regulatory agency is in bed with the
industry and they use it as a metaphor
but you can you can literally say that
happened with mineral Management Service
and some of the oil and gas companies
that they were supposed to be overseeing
the Inspector General for
inspecting the minerals Management
Service in 2008 found just some really
egregious some R rated
violations of of ethics and and I think
the the best quote that I heard was well
if you're in bed with uh with the people
you're supposed to regulate you can't be
at arm's length which is
pretty much uh
sums it up yeah absolutely
the office of the Inspector General gave
us a glimpse into this culture through
investigative reports that tell
startling stories of the minerals
Management Service and its relationship
with the oil industry
one investigation found director Gregory
W Smith worked for an outside
engineering firm and used his role in
the MMS to connect them with industry
clients he often requested that
subordinates provide him with cocaine
crystal meth and engage in sexual
activities
another investigation revealed that MMS
employees had accepted gifts from the
oil and gas industry on numerous
occasions
these are direct violations of
government ethics standards and one
representative admitted that business
was never conducted at such events
the investigations also found emails
Laden with sexual innuendos from
industry Representatives inviting MMS
officials to parties
there was also evidence that employees
took steps to keep their social contacts
with the industry a secret the
investigation uncovered emails from MMS
employees stating their intendance was
to be quote kept quiet and that they
should RSVP in private
foreign
it was also proven that MMS employees
frequently consumed alcohol
cocaine and marijuana at these functions
as well as had sexual relations with oil
industry Representatives
the minerals Management Service MMS Lake
Charles District where all oil industry
the reports saying oil industry
officials would fill out safety
inspection reports themselves in pencil
and MMS inspectors would then Trace over
them in pen before signing them then
there was the inspector who showed up
for work still high on crystal meth and
the other inspector who inspected four
offshore Rigs of a company he was at the
time negotiating with for a job which he
got the rigs meanwhile got no violations
and the other inspectors have got free
lunches from Big oils and other meals
too and gifts and golfing and shooting
and hunting trips and tickets to the
2005 peach Bowl the bigger problem
perhaps not the gifts but the suggestion
they were unnecessary at a revolving
door agency filled with childhood
friends of employees of the oil industry
a Conoco Phillips employee emailing an
MMS inspector quote ever get bribed they
try all the time every 10 take him I
accept quote gifts from certain people
but we have very strict ethic standards
as you could imagine certain people the
Conoco Phillips employee asks meaning
women know the MMS inspector writes
meaning good friends that I wouldn't
write up anyway MMS was asleep at the
wheel and that needs to be corrected
they were more of a lap dog as opposed
to a watchdog and the fact that BP's
plans were approved when they talked
about walruses and seals we don't have
any water systems and seals down here so
obviously either nobody read it or
somebody read it didn't even pay
attention to it and you know it's
probably worse if they read it and
improved it you can understand maybe not
reading it MMS adopted wholesale for its
oil and gas drilling best practices
proposals of the American petroleum
Institute and then they made most of
those best practices only suggestions
there's been virtually no enforcement
according to the MMS website between
2000 and 2009 civil penalties averaged
less than 130 dollars per well per year
on our outer continental shelf and only
three criminal referrals were made to
the department since 1990. in the last
20 years
add it all up
and there is no real question
MMS was a captive regulator
give them some penalties that that will
that will give them incentive you know
not to do this no matter how much money
they get under the table and all that
kind of stuff if they're going to go to
prison for the rest of their life for
getting in bed with BP in you know you
need you know you don't let them retire
with their with you know replace them
and let them retire and you know that
it's been it's been too pedal too softly
you know they need they need some real
penalties on the people who's supposed
to be the Watchdog if they're not the
Watchdog you know China takes them out
and shoots them I don't think we can do
that but that's that's you know you need
to get serious with these people
finally everything was becoming clear
deregulation and the government's faith
in Big Industry spawned these types of
incestuous relationships and led the
government officials to Simply look the
other way while BP operated at the
expense of the American public
and the environment
[Music]
although the MMS requires some companies
to identify what they can do to reduce a
Project's environmental impact the
agency grants hundreds of waivers each
year
it was these types of federal waivers
that essentially gave BP complete
control over its drilling projects
in fact just before the Deepwater
Horizon explosion
a senior director from BP America wrote
to the council saying these exemptions
would help the industry avoid
unnecessary paperwork and time delays
[Music]
traveling further down the coast more
and more upset residents government
officials and Specialists wanted to
speak out such as Billy nungesser
president of plaquemines Parish he is a
staunch political force in Louisiana
state government who had first-hand
experience dealing with BP from the
beginning of this disaster
he had discovered that BP's only concern
seemed to be protecting their bottom
line at almost any cost
for 11 people who were on a drilling
platform when it exploded sending up a
wall of fire the explosion sent six
people to USA Medical Center one of them
was sent to the hospital's Burn Unit
this rig is more than 50 miles Southeast
of Venice off Louisiana's tip I stood in
Venice and listened to the radio
transmission as they pulled people out
the water and they kept those men on the
back of that boat for 24 hours
that's when you knew
something was wrong with this company it
was being run by a bunch of lawyers
why they didn't bring those people into
Venice I was standing by with our
ambulances waiting to care for them they
kept them on a boat for 24 hours
that in itself is Criminal
and it started from there and went
downhill
[Music]
and we read that oil workers from the
rig were held in seclusion on the Open
Water for up to two days after the April
20 explosion while attorneys attempted
to convince them to sign legal documents
stating that they were unharmed by the
incident the men claimed that they were
forbidden from having any contact with
concerned loved ones during that time
and we're told that they would not be
able to go home until they signed the
documents they were presented with after
being awake for 50 harrowing hours
Stephen Davis caved in and signed the
papers he said most of the others did as
well
do you think this is an appropriate way
to treat people that experience that
imagine what it would have been like to
be in that situation so you eventually
made it in the Lifeboat to a supply ship
and then back to shore to a hotel which
is where you're asked by Transocean to
sign this this waiver that I have in my
hand here which says you were asked I
was not a witness to the incident
requiring the evacuation and have had no
first-hand or personal knowledge
regarding the incident you put your
signature to that you're also asked if
you were injured and you said I was not
injured as a result of the incident or
the evacuation why did they say to you
that they wanted you to sign these
they told me me and my wife were
actually about to leave the hotel to
come home they caught me right before I
went out of the door they told me it was
just a statement saying that I was off
tower that I wasn't working I didn't see
what happened leading up to the incident
and uh you know me and my wife are just
trying to get home to see the rest of
our family and they said just you know
sign here initial here initial Here sign
this
tragedy of the 11 people out there many
of these people came from from our
communities and so it was a there was
really a uh you know a human tragedy
there that probably wasn't felt as much
in other parts of the of the country but
it was very much feltier people knew
these people and uh
um and and grieved with the families and
um
uh initially the well is is considered
pretty far offshore uh it was it was
thought that you know we we thought well
they'll they'll get it under control you
know they had the blowout Preventer on
there and so we we oh you know our our
hopes were raised every day and then
dashed and raised and dashed and I don't
know how many times that happened for
four days this bill was thought to have
been contained all the while crude oil
was pumping into the Gulf 42 000 gallons
a day are gushing out but should the
well itself open 100 times more crude
could spew into the water it could take
vastly longer to contain than previously
thought
my initial reaction was I felt terrible
for the
families of the people who lost their
lives on the rig and I thought nothing
of the fact that well they might not be
able to plug this thing I figured it'd
be like any other
disaster or any any other accident in
that type of Industry will a week and a
half two weeks go by and they plug it up
and boom boom it off around the rig and
that's the end of it the funerals go on
for the Lost lives of the workers but I
don't think anybody had any idea
what that was going to lead to and
I was kind of one of the ones I stayed
real positive once I started once
everybody started to kind of realize
just how bad this could possibly be
I try to stay positive that's the only
way that I can deal with things and I
was thinking oh well you know maybe it's
not it's a naturally occurring
um products and maybe it won't be that
toxic on the environment maybe there's
not near as much as they're saying
that's leaking and
there's only so much that you can tell
yourself when you go out there and see
that stuff every day and just thinking
God you know we go out there and our
boat looks looks like we've been in a
battlefield stuff you know all over the
place nasty shovels and all all over the
boat and uh after a day of doing that
you just saying to yourself This golf
that I basically my way of life could
possibly be over for a long time and
that was the hardest pill for me to
swallow and I had a hard time after
seeing how bad it really was staying
positive there are many checks before
you get to activating the blowout
preventer that is the ultimate Fail-Safe
mechanism and for whatever reason we
don't understand that yet but we clearly
will as a consequence of both our
investigation and federal investigations
it failed to operate in November of two
last year Transocean put out the blow up
preventer from the ocean floor because
its Shear Rams weren't working the lower
annular would not close and the upper
upper annular had been stripped through
the through during a Well Control event
this is an annular blowout preventer
it's actually a 20 inch bore the ones
used on the horizon were higher pressure
and 18 and three quarter inch bore but
there would have been two roughly this
size and the blowout preventer stack and
these are primarily the the primary the
the main
um
devices used to actually seal off the
well bore either to prevent a kick or
during testing and they basically have a
rubber elastomer that that can expand
and contract with hydraulic pressure to
seal off the weld board we know that BP
was aware of this because Transocean and
again it's document number 12 there in
our binder reflect conference calls with
BP about the problems with this blow up
preventer just before he lands he
realizes he has not engaged his landing
gear so he puts the landing gear and the
landing gear doesn't get down in time
and the plane crashes so we have an
investigation on how do we get better
landing gears and to me that's what we
have here we're looking at the wrong
thing with it the blower we're spending
too much time looking at the blowout
preventers the blowout preventers of the
landing gear and what we should be
focusing on is the procedures that were
done as you can see your engineers said
that if you used a long string of casing
think quote it is unlikely to be a
successful cement job you would be
unable to fulfill MMS regulations and
there would be an open annulus to the
Wellhead and I have that on the screen
now those are serious risks of failed
cement job a violation of MMS safety
regulations an open pathway for gas to
travel to the top of the well
the same document says that if you use
the liner and tie back approach which is
what Exxon Mobil and other companies
said you should have used you would have
avoided or lessened these risks yet BP
apparently overruled the warnings of its
own engineers and chose the more
dangerous option how can you explain
that decision by BP why were the safety
recommendations of your own Engineers
ignored
I wasn't involved in any of the decision
making
to have a blowout you have to have a
sequential type of errors and what the
first thing was is that they ran this
long string of pipe in there that was
that's number two was the installation
of the pipe and the procedures they used
to and were wrong from what I understand
they were in a hurry and they did not
wait for additional centralizers to get
there so the experts said you need 21.
then and if we can put up the first
slide a BP employee essentially wrote to
that expert and said well we've only got
six
and we don't have time to deal with this
problem
a time to British Petroleum was money
this rig was 45 days late it cost you
five hundred thousand dollars a day and
people's obvious attention were about
time which meant money so what happened
then
well another British Petroleum person a
Sentimental saying we really need to
follow the model here he kicked it up to
Mr guide if we could have the second
slide Mr guide came back and said I
don't like the fact this is going to
take 10 hours to do even though another
British Petroleum person had said we're
going to fly 15 things in they can be
here tomorrow morning
Mr guide said
I don't like the 10 hours
and it didn't happen
so what we have is is that the a number
of things I didn't centralize it they
didn't circulate long enough they ran
the wrong type of the wrong type of
float equipment the they didn't have
enough cement volume and they didn't
and the type of cement they used may not
have been correct so you have a number
of things there is there any other well
to your knowledge in the Gulf of Mexico
that is has been done in the same manner
as this well that was being drilled
under the Deepwater Horizon
there are many wells in the Gulf of
Mexico are there any other whales where
you haven't put the proper number of
centralizers yeah many words in the Gulf
of Mexico that have the same casing
design there are many Wells that have
been drilled where the same same cement
procedure now have the minerals and
Management Service people been there and
looked over those with a fine-tooth comb
everything that we do is subject to
regulatory oversight are you changing
your procedures at those Wells as a
result of things that you've encountered
in your investigation as we learn
outside apologies as we learn from our
investigation we will make appropriate
changes
as I've as I've already indicated the
potential Devastation to the Gulf Coast
its economy
and it's people
require us to continue our Relentless
efforts to stop the leak and contain the
damage
there's already been a loss of life
damage to our Coastline to fish and
wildlife into the livelihoods of
everyone from fishermen to restaurant
Hotel owners
you know they had even less confidence
in where this oil was heading told us
that we need to have a sense of urgency
and we need to start working to protect
ourselves and we had our first impact on
May 12th uh three days after declaring
emergency with tarball sitting the beach
and then seven days later we had our
first Major Impact with heavy brown
crude oil ending up basically scattered
most of the 12 miles of beach that we
have here at Fusion Beach so
it was so unbelievably different from
one day to the next it was just a joke
we had different bosses every day we had
different people we were answering to we
had different uh partner boats different
people on our task force we would just
get trained in doing something and felt
like we were like
okay we're trained we're adequate to do
this job and then they they tell us to
go do something else tell us hey why
don't you go check on that boom wool
we're getting pretty good picking up
this whole won't you let us keep doing
this we're gonna keep our Waters clean
no we need you over here checking this
boom after 67 other boats have already
checked it so it was like that every day
I mean then
I mean I could go on all about getting
paid you know you're going to get paid
and within a week after submitting your
invoice yeah my ass it was it was the
whole thing was just a debacle he came
in here and they put me out of the
shrimp business they put me out of the
fish business they put me out the retail
business because they took out tourists
away they put us out the ice business
because that we make 130 tons of ice
today for and if the shrimp ain't
running they don't need no ice and the
only thing we had left was the fuel
business and and BP brought in outside
is from Texas
that don't pay no taxes over here don't
pay nothing and just I mean I I asked
them if they wanted my dog and my wife
too you might as well take everything I
got you know they all showed up you know
I
I can't fish right now
there's a there's a saying that I do do
what I do best and that's fish you know
do what you do best and pray for the
rest good friend of mine told me that
years ago and it's it's kind of stuck in
my head and it it's what I do I am a
charter fisherman
this is this is what you call me not a
disaster this is a I don't know what you
want to call it but this is the worst
that it could ever happen it's not just
not just us
you know hey we got people from
Mississippi
Alabama Florida Florida we have a lot of
people for that come fish off of here
King Miracles and Snappers that fish are
there too Mississippi comes over here
shrimp so it's not just Louisiana it's
going to be effective we have people
from Texas come here just to work these
areas so you know it's it's it's
everybody's gonna be effective with this
uh oil spill everybody
oil spill hit at the absolute worst time
for our community the businesses we have
here all local family-owned businesses
we don't have very many if any big
corporations that are that are set up in
town operating and so they really
throughout the summer Bank their money
that's when they earn the money there's
about 100 days of summer we try to sneak
through the fall and over the winter and
kind of get by until spring break this
year 2010 Spring Break season was a
breakout year we had
uh good growth we had eight or nine
percent growth in tourism we had good
money flowing in people had after the
different hurricane Seasons that we had
had and had some rebuilding and some
growth then we had a downturn in the
economy all of a sudden this seemed to
be the year where it was up ticking and
so before the season started which is
really our Memorial Day starts our our
summer season before it got here it
never got started we had the brakes put
on and struggled all summer long and now
I'm hoping that the businesses can
survive through the winter through
another down period and be prepared in
springtime so we're fighting not
necessarily for 2010 anymore now we're
fighting to survive to get to 2011 next
year to make sure that the businesses
that are here can be here next year it
was double-digit decline in business
some 20 percent some of the real estate
folks are down 30 percent these
businesses in Pensacola
thrive on a June July August vacation
period that's when they make their money
it's when they save their money to make
them through the rest of the year
and that business was down appreciably
and there was some business that were
saying we don't know if we can make it
bothers me that they'll hire people from
out of town out of state
and won't hire me this is my living this
is my way of life I want it back
Larry thanks very much breaking news
tonight potentially chilling news a
leading expert who you'll hear from in a
minute has examined this video of oil
gushing into the Gulf of Mexico and what
he says is horrifying the leak which the
Coast Guard estimates that 5 000 barrels
a day could be far worse 10 times worse
and that's the bottom end of his
estimated range which means that this
expert is talking about at a bare
minimum about the equivalent of one
Exxon Valdez spill every four days I
think they lied about the amount of oil
that was going into the Gulf immediately
I will say that l-i-e lied
you know they knew that more oil was
going into the Gulf than they first
admitted okay their efforts to cap the
well their efforts to do this is
whatever that that's that's all fine and
dandy but
uh
foreign
all in all I wasn't very happy with BP
there's an area called Barataria Bay and
I would suggest you go look it up about
a week and a half ago there was no oil
in baratari Bay that section was
scheduled to be covered by the barrier
plan that still to this day hasn't been
approved now today there's oil thick oil
coming into Barataria Bay and so you're
not showing the sense of urgency and
whether it's you or the federal
government we've got oil in Barataria
Bay when we had a plan a month ago to
keep the oil out of Barataria Bay and so
when people are here and that
everything's being done I'm going to
tell you on the ground it's not getting
done and I don't know what you need to
do differently but you need to go do
something differently and if it's not
you that's blocking it you need to tell
somebody who's blocking it because it's
being blocked and it's not getting done
on the ground and we don't have the
luxury of time this shouldn't be
happening tropical storm they will bring
a boom out to safety then last night
they were bringing the same boot out
boom out because it was the defective
Chinese boom so what is it we will lie
to we continue to be lied to and I told
the second command Commander I just came
from meeting with
I told everything I don't hold back and
she says well I don't expect you to
trust me
[Music]
I say it I need to show you by action I
said you absolutely do and I said from
this moment on you have an opportunity
here's my phone numbers for any
equipment Moves In This Parish I deserve
a phone call
so there's your chance after it became
obvious we won't have to deal with it
then the focus and the working
relationship with BP was how do we deal
with it how do we clean it up how do we
get it skimmed before we get here it
gets here how do we protect our
Backwater areas you know that kind of
working relationship which started off
pretty Rocky because they had
transitioning people in and out before
they ever have anybody permanently
located here and we were dealing with
one guy one week and they'd take a
two-week reprieve and be gone and we'd
be dealing with somebody else and there
was no consistency I felt like we were
completely in the dark no one knew
anything scientists didn't know anything
you couldn't get any information out of
anyone that you thought should know
something I mean I worked at Hopedale
when they were just setting up the
volunteer system and no one there knew
anything that was going on I mean you'd
walk to the fish and wildlife trailer
and they didn't know what was going on
and you know it just really was
blank it was a blank and I said home I
still don't know who I call Alma The
Wizard of Oz it's some man hiding behind
a curtain because nobody they still
couldn't give me a name well I'll find
out who went home I said well when you
do let me know because we'll travel at
Yellow Brick Road together because I
can't buffer the life of me to see how a
town a homer can make so many decisions
without having a name behind it
Communications were not what they should
be I think everybody would agree to that
on the unified command of course was
over in Mobile and what our premise was
that we in Pensacola knew our beaches we
knew our Bays we knew our bios we knew
how to take care of them let us have
more control but all the control all the
requests had to go through that
particular chain of command and it took
a long time and it was very very
frustrating because as I said before we
knew we had this horrible problem but
there were so many questions as to how
to combat it it was a huge unknown PP
out of the way would raise the question
to replace them with what
only BP he said has the equipment and
expertise to plug a leak a mile below
the surface the government does not and
he said he's still confident BP with
aggressive pressure from the government
will get the job done went there down
told me yesterday
I'm 51 in charge are you a little
pregnant you kiss your sister I mean
what what what's 51 in charge
either you're into what kind of lead it
tells you hey look we're going into war
but I'm 51 if you get shot that's on the
49 that ain't in charge you know if we
win this you I mean how do you tell the
troops hey guys let's go fight this war
I'm 51 in charge
it's a business deal
now we are operating six remote operated
Vehicles simultaneously around the
blowout preventer both monitoring the
blood preventer and trying to close in
the flow of oil development driller 3 is
now on location and we expect to start
drilling the relief well within 48 Hours
also a new technique identified
yesterday afternoon which is to try to
deploy dispersants at the source at the
location subsea
well what they told us was the
disbursements would break it up make it
sink to the bottom and it wouldn't come
ashore that I was being paranoid it
wasn't going to come ashore it was going
to stay offshore
and three weeks four days from that time
Pastor Luther got inundated with oil and
I went back out
five days in a row then on the seventh
day I put brought Anderson Cooper and
the governor out there
and a week later I brought in Anderson
Cooper back there still nobody did
anything and then the third week still
it was almost a month that all sat out
there with birds diving in the oil
all efficient in that area died
there was no life in that Marsh and that
Marsh was dead it'll it'll it'll wash
away in south Louisiana will start about
a half mile Inland that Marsh will be
gone next year
in the dictionary.com definition of
disperse one to drive or send off in
various directions to scatter to what
definition too to spread wildly
disseminate to dispel cause to vanish so
really what they're doing if you get to
the core of this and and keep me honest
on this but really what they're doing is
making us not be able to see the
disaster that is in our Gulf they're not
fixing anything we just can't see it
anymore the difference here is that we
have put these surfactants out at
unprecedented quantities it's an open
ocean spill
the other unprecedented part of this is
that we've put surfactants at the
Wellhead a mile down in the water so we
have dispersed oil through the entire
water column
now what was misleading about what EPA
has been coming out with they said that
oil and oil plus dispersants there's no
difference in toxicity of these two
the difference that they're glossing
over that that's technically true that
oil and oil plus dispersants have the
same toxicity or similar toxicity on a
concentration per concentration basis
right they have similar toxicity the
difference is the bioavailability and
this is what was misleading about the
pronouncements that the where they keep
saying over and over again the
government's saying that there's no
difference in the toxicity of the oil
and the oil plus dispersions what that
glosses over is that with the oil plus
dispersants you have increased the
bioavailability which increases the
Toxic effect it doesn't necessarily
increase the toxicity of the molecules
but it increases the Toxic effect
because it increases bioavailability
our workers our fishermen went out and
worked on the oil spill response and
they were told oh the oil is non-toxic
it's going to be as safe as pancake
syrup and people got sick people were
coughing
headaches dizziness nausea it's like a
TB Ward out there I mean everybody's
hacking and choking and coughing what is
going on and I said well I don't know
but surely the medical doctors will take
care of this and again this is another
example of we trusted the medical
community we trusted the federal and
state laws that are put in place to
protect workers and it turns out there
was loopholes driven into all those laws
by the oil companies and by the
petrochemical industry so that those
laws all missed that the workers were
sick because of oil from the axon Valdez
and the chemical dispersants that were
used so no nobody took care of them
either and I still am dealing now with
cleanup workers from the axon Valdez 21
years later who are saying you know I
thought I had the Valdez crud in 1989
that's what Exxon told us just a little
cold a little flu I didn't think I'd
have it for 14 years 18 years 21 years
what is wrong with me
hearing story after Story of BP's
immoral profit-motivated operations and
the accompanying negligence that caused
the explosion which claimed 11 lives
the human effects of this spill were
becoming more apparent on a visceral
level
that they were playing the oil spill in
the Gulf I realized that it was deja vu
all over again
it was me and my crew out there cleaning
and becoming sick not being able to
breathe and suffering with the flu-like
symptoms with stomach disorder
it would become like bronchitis and when
we went to the doctor they only said
it's the flu and it's going around and
everyone has it
more and more stories about sick
fishermen are beginning to surface
they're out in the Gulf many of them all
day every day working to clean up the
spill many blame the chemicals BP is
using one fisherman told me tonight he
felt like he was going to die over the
weekend
it's like a
sniffing gasoline or something
you know uh and I steal it with Mayors
are popping right now I'm still coughing
up stuff I feel real weak
got all the tingling Marine toxicologist
Ricky Ott says the chemicals used by BP
can wreak havoc on a person's body and
even lead to death the volatile organic
carbons are they act like a narcotic on
the brain and at high concentrations
what we learned in axon Valdez from
carcasses of harbor seals and sea otters
it actually literally fried the brain
brain lesions Congressman Charlie malasa
won something done he sent a letter to
the Obama Administration calling for
temporary health care clinics to be set
up close by so that they can be
immediate attention uh to any people
that feel that they have problems uh
adverse problems that are caused by the
inhalation or exposure to the uh
according to testimony we heard in
Louisiana still BP failed to provide
respirators to the workers exposed to
the crude oil and the workers
experienced Health impacts the workers
were afraid to speak up due to the
potential to lose their jobs those
fishermen who would tempted to wear
respirators while working were
threatened to be fired by BP due to the
workers using the respirators do you
know anything about that I'm not aware
of that now the Federal Environmental
Protection Agency has been tracking
what's in the air by using a mobile
truck and seven monitoring stations
located mainly in Saint Bernard and
plaquemines parishes they are looking
for evidence of several compounds
including hydrogen sulfide and volatile
organic compounds or vocs like Benzene
which commonly known as swamp gas a
normal level ranges from 5 to 10 parts
per billion at the Venice station on May
2nd the levels recorded were 30 parts
per billion the next day the reading was
nearly 40 times that at nearly 1200
parts per billion and the day after that
it dropped down to 46 before Rising the
next day to more than a thousand the air
quality is not good we've been having
trouble you know I've been seeing people
sick you know Eyes Crying a lot nasal
passages stopped up
sore throat you know it's uh I don't
think it's safe you know my wife just
refused to leave my daughter got sick
it was my daughter she's 14. and uh we
took her to the emergency room she was
having a headache real bad and all that
thing and also I took to the emergency
room and they did test and they couldn't
find nothing wrong with it so and doctor
said follow-up and that actually still
has her shoes to her so we took it to
another doctor and they drew him blood
and it and they found chemicals in her
urine and all like
different kind of chemicals the
President also came here as a Salesman
to convince vacationers to come on down
beaches all along the Gulf Coast are
clean they are safe and they are open
for business
that's one of the reasons Michelle Sasha
and I are here News 5 is doing some
testing of our own News 5 investigation
took us from Gulf Shores to Orange Beach
to Katrina key to the Dolphin Island
Marina we collected samples of water
sand and when we saw kids digging do you
mind if we get some water out of here uh
sand hole here
sample of that too Bob Naaman is a
chemist with nearly 30 years of
experience he just did our water and
sand for oil and petroleum Gulf Shores
beach water right where people were
swimming showed 66 parts per million
the sand where beachgoers are walking
has 211 parts per million
sample was a spot in Orange Beach where
again we found kids playing and we found
our highest content of oil and petroleum
221 parts per million but the tests
didn't stop there the sample we haven't
yet told you about is the one collected
from Dauphin Island Marina have you ever
seen this sample exploded right in his
lap I mean like almost instantaneous
actually maybe one second
that's just weird the results surprised
even our chemist we think that it most
likely happened due to the presence of
either methanol or methane gas or the
presence of the dispersant corrects it
cross the Gulf there were stories of
sick people I mean emergency room puking
Brown peeing Brown this is internal
hemorrhaging this is what the EPA
whistleblower Hugh Kaufman was talking
about this is what the material safety
data sheets talk about internal
hemorrhaging I think that the use of
dispersants is is Criminal I mean
essentially by allowing BP to use
dispersants rather than forcing them to
come and skim and remove the oil from
the top of the of the gulf surface
we had legally allowed them to use the
gulf our goal as their disposal unit for
oil I mean that's dispersants don't make
the oil go away they simply make it
smaller they make it dissolve into the
water they make it break down to where
it's true to where Oil eating microbes
can break it down at a faster rate
absolutely true but what it also means
is the other billions of organisms in
the Gulf that aren't oil eating microbes
can also absorb it and bioaccumulate it
at a much faster rate there were many
studies after Valdez for a decade after
Exxon Valdez
and and the overall message from all of
these peer-reviewed scientific studies
was dispersants you including core exit
increase the bioaccumulation of the pahs
the carcinogenic component of oil by
anywhere from 12 to 50 000 times
so our laws are set up to where BP was
allowed to dispose of their oil into our
ghost food web essentially
big mistake news a report that they had
they said that the Snapper and mullet
was safe to eat
well you can catch snapping this Bay
snapping while it was safe to eat but
shrimp and crabs stay away from them
they all habitat in the same Bay
nowhere else there in this Bay I mean
you know if you want to say well how can
snap and mullet be safe and shrimp and
crabs that side by side I mean liberally
side by side they're not safe something
don't make sense with that picture that
picture doesn't sail with me at all it
was uh if that was what it was meant to
be said and they said it that way
they're wrong and I still wouldn't sell
anything until
all of these species are safe the
dispersed oil is going to affect all of
that it's going to affect the eggs the
larvae the food everything in the
Plankton is going to be impacted and so
that area that's been affected is is is
it's you know you can't probably
shouldn't go as far as say sterilized
but I mean the impact is huge my
livelihood the money that that I live
off of comes from selling fish and stuff
yeah I want it to be open but what I
personally eat anything that I catch
that I certainly have my uh my ballots I
would be a little bit apprehensive we
expect to see a substantial reduction in
the amount overall amount of dispersant
used primarily because they shouldn't
need to be spraying it if they're able
to disperse it earlier if we start to
see dispersing chemicals in that water
or anywhere in the water column then
we're going to tell we're going to
recommend strongly to the Onsen
coordinator that we stop it was
everywhere it was
obviously certain days will be worse
than others depending on how strong of a
south wind we had or what the current
was doing but
um
as I've said before it was weird how
being a fisherman and knowing the gulf
like I feel I know it knowing what
direction and how fast the current's
moving and what the wind's doing I mean
there was absolutely no Rhyme or Reason
to being in the stuff for two weeks
straight everywhere and no one there was
a bunch of it to the east of us when
we've got a current out of the East and
it should be just right over here the
next day and is gone just little white
bubbles
and um
it was we heard rumors that I can't
confirm it but I mean there was there's
no doubt they were sinking to stuff
they're spraying it with airplanes at
night I've got some friends I'm not
going to mention their names but they
worked offshore
stayed offshore for several days at a
time and they would tell them between 12
and 4 stay in your cabins because we're
going to bomb it we're going to spray it
from my understanding that was not legal
that was not authorized by the
government for them to do that they did
it anyway out of sight out of mind has
been their policy and they they lived up
to that part of it BP life from day one
and they're still lying to people so you
know what's the difference you know we
asked them to quit spraying that
dispersal you know because that's a
killer but they want to keep on hiding
they keep on spraying they still they
want to hide that oil under the ground
under the water where nobody can see it
which is wrong let the son of a
come to the top of the water and let
them skim it
foreign
for a long time being against use of
that dispersant I'm not against use of a
dispersion there's a lot of organic
dispersants and that's what I was
talking about earlier people can't get
their products to be P to be considered
I've seen a lot of organic distortions
that one could have been used I have a
problem with the dispersants they use
because it's car exit there's there's
corporate relationships between BP and
the company that
manufactures core exit it's banned in
the United Kingdom if it's not good
enough for the United Kingdom it
shouldn't be good enough for the Gulf of
Mexico number one number two uh I think
this this person may be the solution may
be worse than the problem uh and three
the dispersion has actually complicated
the skimming of this oil because it's
forced it underneath and it's also been
like trying to track a ghost so uh and I
again again I think the federal
government failed is there because again
just like we talked about form MMS now
Department of motion and energy the EPA
has been basically a lap dog and not
Watchdog because they've requested and
they've sat on record they've told BP
not to use it but guess what they
continue to use it despite that EPA told
him stop using it because it's toxic to
human beings BP said right now we've
learned there's not anything else out
there in the kind of quantity they need
so they're putting something toxic to
human beings and harmful to plant to sea
life in the sea
you know it's interesting Shepherd an
Exxon report an Exxon report some years
ago showed that the core exit is
actually four times more toxic than the
crude oil itself would you say that
again in this case these dispersants
were used in massive quantities almost 2
million gallons so far to hide the
magnitude of the spill and save BP money
and the government both EPA NOAA Etc
have been sock puppets for BP in this
cover-up Now by hiding the uh amount of
spill uh BP is saving hundreds of
millions if not billions of dollars in
fines and so from day one there was
tremendous economic incentive to use
these dispersants to to hide the
magnitude of the gusher that's been
going on for almost three months one
thing that I did want to mention to you
Amy that's occurred in most
investigations back even in the War gate
days people said follow the money and
that's correct in this case you've got
to follow the money who saves money by
using these toxic dispersants well it's
BP but then the next question I've only
seen one article that describes it who
owns BP
I
think
when you look and see who owns BP you
find that it's the majority ownership a
billion shares is a company called
BlackRock Vanity Fair just did recently
an article about Mr Fink and his
connections with Mr Geithner Mr Summers
and others in the administration so I
think what what's needed we now know
that there's a cover-up it was becoming
obvious that Americans could no longer
blindly trust their Watchdog agencies
today the federal government is
releasing a new scientific analysis that
addresses the question where did the oil
go
the conclusions key conclusions of the
report is that the vast majority of the
oil has either evaporated or been burned
skimmed and recovered from the Wellhead
or dispersed and much of the dispersed
oil is in the process of relatively
rapid degradation
a significant amount of this is a direct
result of the very robust Federal
response efforts new evidence has badly
shaken the Obama administration's Rosy
narrative about the alleged
disappearance of most of the oil that
gushed into the Gulf of Mexico from VPS
blown out well early this month a report
by government scientists declared three
quarters of the oil had vanished either
collected or dispersed but numerous
reports contradict the administration's
sanguine picture of the cleanup effort
researchers at the University of Georgia
said about three quarters of the oil is
still lurking below the surface of the
gulf and may pose a threat to the
ecosystem
separately a study released last week by
the University of South Florida
scientists found oil and sediments of an
underwater canyon and evidence that the
oil has become toxic to critical marine
organisms on Thursday a team of
researchers confirmed the existence of a
vast underwater oil plume stretching 21
miles from BP's blown out well
Christopher ready of Woods Hole
oceanographic institution said the
amount of oil in the plume is unknown
[Music]
now it is clear how and why BP with the
help of the federal government willfully
cause This Disaster and continually
tried to sweep this toxic soup under the
rug
I don't give you democrat Republican
independent green party look let's face
it
they dropped the ball and not protesting
these toxins or these dispersants being
spreading our water we don't know the
long-term effect
if that wasn't bad enough
desperate out of work Gulf Coast
residents were forced to do the
Hazardous sweeping without proper safety
gear
the final insult was the cleanup
worker's gross underpayment
which leads us to the last subject
compensation
the only way you intend to pay those
claims is if it comes through this fund
is that yourself this is a very large
sum of money to pay claims I'm sorry 20
billion dollars is a very large fund to
pay claims from it is a large fund and
is it's your view that part of what that
fund will be used for is to pay people
for their long-term health care costs
incurred as a result of this bill that
will be a decision for the independent
adjudicator well if they asked you what
you thought would you say yes the health
care cost should be paid for from this I
think that's something that I will leave
him to decide that's why we've appointed
an independent adjudicator so he's the
guy that said
all of the agent orange
suits
from the Vietnam War
he's the fella that was the trust fund
administrator for 9 11 after the
collapse of the World Trade Center
and you can imagine how complicated that
was
with especially with all of the deaths
that occurred from that tragedy
he is the fella that was called upon to
Virginia
in the Virginia Tech massacre
to solve those problems
here we have the world's expert
to step in and smooth out this process
and to see that just and do compensation
is given to people who have suffered as
so many of us have suffered Ken Feinberg
thank you
I want to thank I want to thank Senator
Nelson I'm here because Senator Nelson
said be here
and when Senator Nelson asks you to do
something
you do it what's going to happen to our
fish our crabs our shrimp our oysters
people are not buying out Seafood now
because of these toxins Haagen British
Petroleum make us whole on that issue
you seem to be saying
that
oysters that there's going to be
long-term potential long-term
devastation
to the ability to catch
quota
I don't know if that's true do you know
if that's true there may be no long-term
impact
Senator Nelson mentions my credibility
doing these other projects
my credibility will last a very very
short time
if the money doesn't get delivered here
to eligible claimants
beginning when I take over
with the Gulf Coast Claims facility on
August 23rd less than two weeks away BP
has pounded home this message BP has got
to make things right and they're
spending a hundred million dollars on a
PR Blitz to tell the rest of the country
they're making this whole guys it's not
true it's not true and mayor Tony Cannon
of Orange Beach Alabama devastated when
tourists stayed away so
independent Claims Administrator Ken
Feinberg has not made things better so
we're very upset with the overall
performance of Ken Feinberg in an
interview Feinberg acknowledges problems
we haven't processed all of the claims
as quickly as we should have I oversold
this program at the beginning and I'm
paying the price for it I do not work
for BP I'm still sitting over here they
cut me instead of helping me they cut me
from 5 000 to 2300 a month so you tell
me
what's happened with and it's not just
the BP scenario it's it happens across
the board in America we have this
because we we value capitalism so much
you think capital and capitalism really
is a is a great system it's potentially
one of the best systems in the world but
it's become so remarkably flawed lately
part of the flaw is that the people that
you talk to along the coast probably if
you ask them what their sense of
corporate America is they don't really
see them as criminals sometimes now if
we dress if we dress them up in an
Armani suit and we put 500 shoes on them
and we put Rolex watches on their hands
and we put them in a silk tie all of a
sudden they may be completely a
psychopath but they're in their heart
they're still a criminal we look at them
differently than we do the kid who has
three ounces of pot in a bag that we
throw into prison for two years
now a corporation in this in this
setting let's just say what it is they
killed 11 people right okay that they're
for all practical purposes they created
mass murder but still you can't find
people understanding that they're
criminals because they look different
they're from Wall Street they're they
have a British accent they're dressed up
in an Armani suit they have nice looking
shoes they talk intelligently they have
dinner with politicians they know
celebrities and our culture doesn't
allow us to understand that they're
really just criminals
the year before the spill BP sales
equaled 239 billion dollars
[Music]
BP's total fines and settlements
were a meager 0.3 percent of this
the oil industry is by far the most
profitable industry in the world and
includes six of the 10 largest
corporations worldwide
this industry is now experiencing a
level of power comparable only to the
era of Standard Oil
we are currently standing at the
crossroads the choices we make in the
next five years will impact our future
Generations like never before
much of the technology and expertise are
readily available
it's a matter of choice
When anybody could convince 13 of idiots
to go vote for you you can win you know
uh you know that's the most
disappointing part of the American
public is that that wanted a few rights
you got left is to go vote and a lot of
people just don't take the time and
don't care and look where are we at you
know we must summon the willpower to
force government corporations and Wall
Street to become responsible for their
actions before we reach the point of no
return
we just
[Music]
the future is uh up for grabs you might
say
it really is up for grabs and uh we got
to do something about it and that the
only people are going to do something
about you just mentioned are the people
that care
you know and that's most people
that's most people most people care
about their country most people care
about this you know the dissonance and
the radicals get the exposure from that
pressure we're talking about a while ago
you know you you have a peace rally in
one corner and you have a wall rally in
the other who gets the coverage
this peace rally is not going to get the
coverage the water alley is going to get
tickets for people are going to watch
that's what the news are going to sell
the newspaper so we've got some changing
to do young people
[Music]
I was just talking to my daughter
yesterday I got on a long harangue about
all kinds of things hoping that they did
a better job than we
than we do
um
[Music]
I'm hoping that there that that our
children learn a better balance
with the environment with the economy
with the things you need out of the
environment that there just needs to be
a better stewardship
native Elders say that you know I mean
if you listen to them you know they talk
about the end time prophecies and all
this kind of stuff and they're like oh
everybody's saying it's the end of the
world it's the end of the world and this
native Elder says the world's not gonna
end humans
that humans may end but the world will
still be here
you know
and
there's an old Chippewa Prophecy from
sun bear back in the 20s he said there
will come a day when the earth will
shake herself
to rid herself the pesky humans like a
dog shakes itself to rid itself a fleas
you know and you got to look at the
things that are happening I mean there's
stuff happening around all around the
world every day there's beat something
up enough it doesn't get up again right
you can exceed some threshold and that's
what we always are concerned about with
ecological resilience is where is that
threshold of impact where the system
does not bounce back we've seen this
before one of the best examples is
Georgia's Bank the Cod fishery one of
the most tremendous Fisheries on the
face of the Earth and we fished it darn
near to wiping it out and they're still
caught out there we've backed off the
fishing pressure
but those populations aren't growing
right we've exceeded some resilience
threshold they're not responding they're
not there's no resilience there in the
Cod populations there's something that
we've done by by going too far too much
of an impact have we done that to the
Gulf of Mexico to even one part of it or
all of it or you know have we exceeded
thresholds for the Gulf of Mexico
ecosystem we won't know for years
it means that the this generation that
we pride ourselves in being such
progressives uh that we've changed so
much stuff through baby boomers
it means that everything we told them
they have to ignore
it means that all these promises we made
about how right we were we have to admit
we were we were wrong did we change some
great things sure we you know I'd love
to say we we brought about uh civil
rights to some degree we did we helped
I'd love to say that we gave women
rights that they didn't have before
today yeah I'd like to say that we we
had it we had a positive social impact
but if you weigh the bad decisions we
made along the way if you weighed the
consumerism that ate us up if you uh if
you weigh the uh the culture that we
built that is around celebrity uh it's
around celebrity it's around uh uh it's
around ideas that don't really Advance
us as a culture they entertain us
and we're able to say uh you know we're
able to say we've made some advances I
suppose is a culture entertaining
ourselves making ourselves comfortable
building our houses making our car we've
done some good things I suppose but we
have to tell I have to tell my child to
ignore most of the things I've done
because if if if she doesn't ignore the
things we've made as a baby boomer
generation uh it's it's it's in game
time
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
the way I feel about them right now
that's the way I feel about they keep
burning how are they doing to me now you
know hey
I'm fed up with it you know I'm just
they can burn in hell
[Music]